it was so great to kind of like get a
moment where you felt like you could
still have like a really fun
theater experience i know it's not the
way folks intended but it was really
great to really sort of see these
characters back and doing all this
amazing stuff but
why 1984 why the 80s why do you think
like we had to set the story
in this particular time period there
were a bunch of reasons
one of them was after shooting the first
movie
in 1917 world war one everything was
gray and gloomy
to be able to move on for the next story
where the environment is so alive and so
pop and colorful just felt like super
great but on the philosophical level
um the 80s were
the heights of everything of success
and access and you know it was the time
when people didn't think about the
repercussions of what's going to happen
and we felt like it had a lot of
resembles
uh to nowadays yeah i think it's like
the ostentatiousness of it
that's the part that i was like living
for um
and i can't say that anyone is more
ostentatious than what kristen is
doing with barbara it is just simply
amazing and
they give her so much and i loved
watching y'all go toe to toe
as much as i liked y'all like sort of
having those like bonding moments but
i have to ask about the fight scenes so
what was it like fighting kristen way
cause y'all look like
i hate to say you were having fun but it
looked like you were having fun
we were having fun it was a lot of work
too uh petty really made a point
about you know having um
as minimum amount of cgi as possible
which
was great but it just meant that we had
to
do a lot of the heavy lifting ourselves
so we spent both
kristen and i together and apart we
spent so much
time working out and working with the
stun
teams learning the choreographies and
rehearsing and doing the wire work and
doing the
water work it was like it was a lot
but working with kristen made the whole
experience much more delightful
what did you do
i was just saying the gal like it's so
colorful it's just so audacious and she
said that's why you guys
wanted to do it in the 80s but i'm just
curious for you personally like
what is your connection to that time
frame because i think everybody
approaches a decade differently so what
does it personally
identify to you i came of age and you
know i was in junior high in the 80s and
so
i um or i was in high school too but um
i just remember it as from the point of
view of a teenager it was so much
fun and the movies were amazing and
everything was exciting and everything
seemed
possible i couldn't wait to go travel
the world and go to new york and all
that stuff
so that's what i really remember about
it and i was excited
to capture was that kind of the world
where everything seems possible still
and there really was that kind of
naivete that this way of life would ever
stop
being successful and so it was
interesting to take
wonder woman who's now seen world war
one world war ii
vietnam seeing all of these things and
and collide
her with a time of such opulence and
excess and
naivete when she's not naive and so that
was very
interesting as a character and visually
i just loved that it was so different
from the first movie
i got to see my my wonder woman that i
grew up loving and linda carter
in the right time for her and so i i
loved that about it as well
yeah i definitely felt like the linda
carter vibes the colorful vibes like
all of the it felt like an 80s movie
like a period piece almost like it very
much felt like of that era
um and i but i do have to ask because it
now fits in the timeline differently
has zach tapped you for any like
schneider cut
little little nods back like i'm just
curious if he's now like
seen it and he's going to put some stuff
in there no he hasn't he
he has seen it he's seen the film but i
haven't seen the snyder cut yet and what
he's doing but no he didn't he didn't
require anything
to to his move
no no i know he doesn't need anything
folks are just going to be really happy
to see it let me get it that way
didn't need me to retrospectively yeah
nothing gotcha
no no it's great though but it's in the
canon now that's what's so great about
this is it sets up this whole new
timeline so i really do love that
and then also we have to ask about the
recent news and i just want to know
you probably can't tell us anything but
it's history so we kind of know a little
uh what are you what can you tell us
about cleopatra and why you guys are
teaming up this next time again
cleopatra is such an interesting story
but it's one of those stories that's
never been told really from her point of
view you know
it's only been told by the romans who
hated her and
killed her you know so when you really
it's one of those when you start to look
at the story you realize something very
different than you think was going on
and she was just an
epic legendary powerful
leader and so what an interesting story
gal
is such an incredible person to play it
and so you know that's such a
it's a it's a it's a beautiful project
you know what i'm ready to go i think we
can do better
parachute pants yeah does everybody
parachute now
[Music]
you